Yemen is in the grips of a heat wave
that's pushing the Mercury up to 44
degrees
the capital Sana sits at 2 200 meters
above sea level and generally enjoys
milder temperatures throughout the year
but this is changing
this year is intense it's been felt by
everyone we can feel it at home
especially I even had to install fans
and air conditioners this year
July and August are Yemen's rainy season
temperatures in the capital generally
vary between 15 and 25 degrees Celsius
for those not used to the heat there's a
new best seller on the streets
this year we noticed that the demand for
ice cubes and other ice products has
increased due to the high temperatures
the demand for all ice products whether
mineral water cubes or ice cream has
gone up because of the Heat
ice isn't the only thing in demand
I would have never expected that one day
I will need to buy an air conditioner
here in Sana but it's been a dramatic
change in weather and we're not used to
these high temperatures
so I came here and I am not the only one
most of the residents of sanar are
looking to buy air conditioners fans or
coolers to face their extreme heat
yemenis have faced years of conflict
displacement and economic hardship the
changing climate is proving another
challenge to their daily lives
Michael Apple Al Jazeera